welcome to this video playing chess IPO
one from an Austrian let's see if I can
do this again that is awkward it almost
always leads to interesting play yeah
lots of c-4 players avoids an early d
home okay let's let's use their phone
iam yeah f2 can be a good good spot to
attack and if i take here let's try that
if you if he recaptures yeah i think i
can just play Knight g4 in this position
isn't this good how does see how does he
protect this i think you should have
castled I castle now what what are you
doing then f2 is just under under big
pressure 94 I can still take yeah yeah I
can also take at the end i have e 5 so
it should win material check and have
one in exchange
yeah not sure maybe taking with the porn
was a bit bit more dangerous I don't
know at least I had neato I need to a
complete development now what at least
has some good points in the center that
something but still this is not going to
be enough for in exchange what I
actually would like to do if i manage
something like we need for Andrew Gough
for returning the exchange would be nice
for opponent that the spot on e5 could
be could be a good idea but there's also
just Knight f6 or 95 with them with a
fine position okay if I go Queen h4
there's maybe 95 that's not very easy to
meet I mean yeah easy to meet weather
with a really good reply okay maybe he
wants to play look G 185 Hubbardton okay
this will also just open the position
for my looks uh-huh okay
I latekka form maybe rookie ATM
intending Knight f6 02 okay i can think
of taking it oh I wonder I wonder if I
can go I just got a slight compensation
c5 bishops III Bishop d525 Knight f6
night a queen d6 night and this this
does not look right it does not look
right what about c6c 6 and 993 is not
possible c6 night season I know that c6
looks ugly but i always have c5 later
okay
197 I have Ruby 7am Roxy 896 looks a bit
a bit ugly ok so here I thought Knight
f6 and then intending c5 this was the
whole idea yeah but I have not you for
now and then i can take here
check yeah I think I can just take e5
probably the easiest the easiest way to
play or is there anything and you think
better even now c5 also not bad ok
Knight e5 Bishop b5 rookie 5 Queen da
time covering and I don't see a movie
really yeah that's that's the easiest ok
let's see you in a thought see five
would work maybe it's not see 5 p-5
Bishop g2 King g2 and don't have a check
here that's really strange hmm
I have Queenie five at the end yeah I
Queen 527 check what I was trying to say
Queenie seven-year pending the Bishop
Bishop g7 s Queen g7 check damn he will
lose the bishop back now abhisek be
success always an irritating move from
not always but quite often an irritating
move for white reason 1c for players and
they don't get the fianchetto in so
easily I thought that may be here after
my capture you should castle first I
cannot take on d3 obviously and he just
can't delay this a moment and maybe
Bishop g5 is a move or something this is
this is the game and it's already done
here why does losing Knight d4 I can I
can also take here that's even even
worse check ya somethin somethin like
this is getting very very ugly so we got
this and really this is just an exchange
I really don't think this much I think I
think I played it okay I don't think
there is a problem this is an
interesting spot the computer I think
approves of that I wasn't so sure him
about this about the because this Bishop
p.m. yeah he can this is possible so I
shouldn't take on e4 may be here yeah I
think I was rejecting the rejecting this
was correct I think the
should should keep keep an advantage
here you can play Bishop f2 actually mmm
gaining the pawn it's probably still
okay but I didn't see that can't hear it
it's probably just gone yeah yeah
blackest winning here yeah b6 always
interesting okay thanks for watching